por ahora el statu quo se mantiene la
Corte Suprema decidió mantener el libre
acceso a la píldora abortiva
mifepristona la orden detiene un fallo
de un juez Federal de Texas que
declaraba inválida la aprobación
otorgada al medicamento por la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos fda hace más de dos décadas
el quinto circuito de apelaciones que
aún debe decidir sobre el caso dejó pie
para varias restricciones en el acceso a
la pastilla pero el pronunciamiento del
máximo tribunal supone un respiro de
alivio para los defensores de los
derechos reproductivos en Estados Unidos
hoy la Corte Suprema suspendió una
decisión que habría socavado el juicio
médico de la fda y pues en riesgo la
salud de las mujeres como resultado la
misión prehistona un fármaco aprobado
por la fda para el aborto con
medicamentos Sigue estando disponible y
aprobado
más que un simple tema de derecho
reproductivos el caso de la mifepristona
abre el debate sobre la autonomía de las
entidades científicas a la hora de tomar
decisiones sobre temas de salud y expone
el alcance de los grupos religiosos y
ultraconservadores en su deseo por poner
fin al aborto en el país
la corte acaba de mandar un mensaje
claro y es que por lo menos no se va a
tomar una decisión como estas de una
forma ligera si bien sorprende que los
jueces alito y los jueces tomas tuvieran
como una un voto disidente sobre esta
decisión igual te muestra que no es un
caso de aborto común y corriente sino es
un caso que tiene implicaciones que van
muchísimo más grandes junto con el
misoprostol la mifepristona es uno de
los dos medicamentos que se usan en los
abortos farmacológicos la combinación es
capaz de interrumpir el embarazo casi
con un 100% de efectividad y es usada en
más de la mitad de los abortos en el
país Desde que la Corte Suprema derogara
el histórico falloud versus White 13
estados de la mayoría republicana han
impuesto prohibiciones a la interrupción
del embarazo y otras más serias
restricciones